(soft music)
- [Narrator] Demand for life-saving
COVID-19 antibody drugs is on the rise.
Just four months ago,
drug maker Regeneron reported an average
of less than 5,000 dose
deliveries per week.
By September, the number
increased to over 150,000 doses.
This is happening as
hospitalizations remain high.
In late August, over
100,000 COVID-19 patients
were hospitalized nationwide,
a daily average not seen
since last winter surge.
This comes as the delta variant
sweeps through the country
and healthcare systems become overwhelmed.
For those who are vaccinated,
severe illness and hospitalization
due to the coronavirus still remains rare,
but millions of adults
remain unvaccinated.
And for high-risk patients who do get sick
doctors are increasingly turning
to antibody drugs to treat them.
To understand why they've
become so critical
in the fight against COVID-19,
you need to understand how they work.
When patients are infected
by the new coronavirus,
their immune systems
should produce antibodies.
These immune proteins bind to the virus
and prevent it from spreading
throughout the body.
Antibodies against COVID-19 do this
by blocking what is
known as a spike protein
on the virus's surface.
This protein normally helps the virus
latch onto and infect cells,
But for some people, their immune system
doesn't produce enough
antibodies to fight off the virus
or it doesn't produce them fast enough.
This is where antibody drugs,
like the ones that Regeneron
and Eli Lilly produce, come into play.
To manufacture these drugs,
researchers isolate
what are called B-cells
from a recovered patients blood.
B-cells are a type of immune system cell
that makes antibodies.
In the lab, the B-cells are then mixed
with spike proteins derived
from the coronavirus.
When scientists identify the B-cells
that are best at latching
onto the spike proteins,
they isolate the genes inside the cells
that produce the most
effective antibodies.
These genes are then placed inside cells
and are grown in bioreactors
to create new antibodies.
And these highly specific antibodies
are concentrated into a liquid solution
and then injected into
sick COVID-19 patients.
This gives the body a
temporary boost of antibodies
that help it fight off infection.
In clinical trials, Regeneron's drug,
which is a combination of
two types of antibodies
reduced the risk of
hospitalization or death
by 70% in people with
mild to moderate symptoms.
This is a big reason
by treatment guidelines
from major health organizations
now recommend the use of
monoclonal antibody drugs
for certain patients.
- So this is a major breakthrough
in the care of COVID-19 patients.
We have expanded our tools
to treat patients with COVID-19.
And this is our first recommendation
for a therapeutic for those patients
with mild, moderate disease.
- [Narrator] The World Health Organization
also recommends the use of
Regeneron's antibody drug
for patients who are severely ill.
- Giving them this additional antibody
seems to show an effect.
And what effect is that?
A reduction in mortality.
- [Narrator] As many hospitals
continue to be overwhelmed,
demand for antibody drugs remains high.
(soft music)